here's what's going on at the movies I  know who I am Matt Damon is back in the  action thriller Jason Bourne which finds  the former assassin searching for the  truth about his past  msg no BHA no be the hilarious comedy  bad mom stars Mila Kunis Kristen Bell  and Kathryn Hahn as moms who decide to  take a walk on the wild side tea a  meeting at 2:00 and we see ho his  stranger for five seconds nerve is a  heart-pounding high-stakes game of dares  where the only way out is to win players  show that your weapons and finally let's  find out what's hot in theaters this  weekend with this week's fan tissa  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket